the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones season 8 finale video well we
are only days away from finally getting
to see how Game of Thrones comes to an
end like I said in my last video I will
absolutely continue to make videos even
after the show is over I haven't made a
whole lot of videos about the books as
of yet and we still have another show
coming out about the Age of Heroes so
those are some other things that I could
always talk about I also want to start
making some videos on some other things
but I haven't decided which other topics
I will cover yet I would love it if you
could leave me some recommendations down
below in the comment section anyways
let's get into today's video as you can
see by the title of the video I want to
talk about what the final scene of Game
of Thrones could be what do you think
the very last scene could be right
before the screen fades to black and we
see the end credits I actually made a
video about this over a year ago but now
that we are only days away from actually
knowing what it will be I want to
discuss it one final time I want to go
over some of the options I have been
thinking about at the end of the video
you can let me know which ones you think
it will be or if you have a totally
different idea of your own now if you
think all the way back to the first
season of the show the opening scene
started at Castle black this is of
course when we were introduced to the
Nights Watch as well as the White
Walkers that opening scene essentially
set the tone for the entire series we
immediately knew that this would be a
very dark and medieval fantasy story
[Applause]
since this is where everything started
maybe it's where everything could end
now obviously the Nights Watch is no
longer what it once was
and as far as we know the night King and
the White Walkers no longer exist
I think it would be very interesting if
the final scene did leave us some sort
of sign that maybe the White Walkers
could return one day but for whatever
reason I don't think the show will do
that I do happen to think the night King
and the White Walkers are gone forever
something I've talked about in my last
video was where will Jon Snow go now
that it looks like him and Danny will
not be living together well based on the
final conversation he had with torment
it did seem like he could end up back in
the north that is where he spent most of
his time not to mention that is also
where he said ghost since John does not
want the Iron Throne and he did seem to
separate himself from Winterfell and
House Stark maybe he does go live out
the rest of his life at Castle black or
somewhere out beyond the wall John could
end up back right where he started and
like I said maybe the show does the same
thing since the opening scene started at
Castle black maybe it ends there maybe
we could see Jon Snow standing back up
on top of the wall looking out into the
distance reflecting on everything that
has happened to him and his family since
House Stark was the first family we were
officially introduced to then maybe the
final scene ends there and which one of
you was a marksman at 10 keep practicing
bran
well didn't think too much bran flexible
um now it's hard to say how many Starks
will be in Winterfell by the end of this
last episode but the show could end with
a scene of the remaining Starks back at
their home they could either be standing
on Winterfell battlements or out in the
godswood they have been the main family
throughout the story so I do think it
would be fitting to end the series back
at Winterfell
I wish we could have seen their families
Valyrian steel sword were forged before
it was over but it's not looking like
that will happen anymore another final
scene I think they could do is some sort
of montage of the various locations
around Westeros we could get an aerial
view of eastwatch-by-the-sea Winterfell
and even King's Landing when you think
about it these have been three of the
main locations in the story and all
three of them have been hit really hard
over the years we had spent so much time
at the wall as well as Winterfell and
King's Landing
if they do want to end this show by
leaving us with a great sense of loss
but also a dream of spring then they
might remind us of how those locations
had suffered because of all the battles
but also show us that they are having
some renovations done in the final scene
they were already starting to do that at
Winterfell the last time we were there
now it will obviously take a very long
time to rebuild King's Landing but they
could show the beginning stages of a
community coming together to clean up as
much as they can then of course if they
want to go in the other direction they
could show us the deconstruction of the
Iron Throne by having it melted down the
Iron Throne has always been considered
as one of the ultimate symbols of power
in Game of Thrones it also represented
the rise of House Targaryen considered
it was created by a Kahn Targaryen in
his dragon balerion the black dread
thousand blades taken from the hands of
Aegon's fallen enemies forged in the
fiery breath of balerion
in the dred there are 2,000 blades there
aren't even 200 I've counted ha I'm sure
you have ugly I don't think it has a
certain appeal even the red keep itself
was constructed thanks to House
Targaryen the fight for who has the
rightful claim over the iron throne is
responsible for the loss of so many
lives now we are at the very end of the
current story and we just saw another
Targaryen burned down nearly all of
King's Landing including the red keep
that her family had made maybe the last
step is melting down the iron throne it
was created by one Aegon Targaryen maybe
we can see it get melted down in the end
by another Aegon Targaryen that could be
an actual sign that things will be done
very differently from here on out one
other scene I think they could do at the
very end might make a lot of fans happy
because I have seen many of you talk
about this before I am of course
referring to Samwell Tarly writing the
story of a Game of Thrones
especially now that he has close friends
what bran Stark he could access any
moment in history that he would want the
final scene could show Samwell sitting
alone writing something down at a desk
at first we won't be able to see what
he's writing but right as the camera
moves over a shoulder we could see him
writing the words the end then he closes
the book and on the cover I could say
something along the lines of a Song of
Ice and Fire
the histories and battles of Westeros or
something like that we did recently get
that scene where a brand talked about
the night king wanting to erase all the
memories of mankind that was followed up
by Sam saying if we forget where we've
been and what we've done we are not men
anymore
we are only animals maybe that was
foreshadowing Sam writing down all the
major events from a game of Thrones to
write histories Holly have to do the
research if you want be able to read
your histories you need a bit of style
I'm not writing a chronicle of the wars
following the death of King Robert the
first so he can sit on his shelf
I'll read but
you don't like the title what would you
call it then possibly something a bit
more poetic let me know if you have any
other ideas for the final scene of the
show I think one of these could work but
maybe you know a better way to end the
last episode anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching the video and I
also want to thank all of you for
continuing to support the channel I hope
you all have a great day I'll see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]